elles sont là juste à côté de la viande
les galettes de hamburgers à base de
plantes ont pris d'assaut les marchés je
suis sûr que ça doit être bon on
entendra parler tout le monde connaît de
la protéine végétale tout le monde
connaît un burger végétal donc toute la
publicité qui a été fait aux alentours
de sol nous allons profiter cet
entrepreneur a fondé vdh gîte une
alternative québécoise à l'américaine
beyond its ses boulettes et sont hachées
végétales sont vendus en épicerie depuis
dix jours
il observe une tendance alimentaire qui
est bien plus qu'une mode selon lui
malgré qu'on peut penser que c'est toute
l'idéologie qu'ils aient des milléniaux
on se voit que c'est vraiment une
conscience sociale qui est en train de
s'installer
donc les gens sont très conscients
aujourd'hui que
la consommation de viande un jour il va
falloir penser à changer ça mouassa 20
étages fait de la recherche dans le
domaine agroalimentaire j'ai jamais vu
j'anticipais qui était pour avoir un
changement bouleversement au comptoir
des viandes un moment donné 600 cas dix
ans mais les choses se passent
extrêmement arrêté c'est vraiment le
facteur bien admis que tout changer
l'entreprise a écoulé pour 67 millions
de dollars de produits entre les mois
d'avril et juin et prévoit maintenant
engranger des revenus de plus de 240
millions de dollars cette année
un succès qui rejaillit sur tous dans ce
supermarché iga de montréal l'espace
consacré aux produits vga triplé dans la
dernière année
on voit vraiment qu'il ya un engouement
pour la protéine végétale et ça va être
aux petites pme québécoises et
canadiennes de prendre avantage de cet
engouement les protéines végétales sont
populaires dans les épiceries mais aussi
dans les restaurants
en plus des w les boulettes bionique
sont maintenant offertes dans tous les
restaurants tim hortons au canada ici
sébastien desrosiers radio-canada mots
rien